eight twenty and eleven seconds
there was a code two call for a mouth
injury
right correct meaning code two again
meaning
just come in the matter of due course
don't no need to rush
yes routine and then at 20
21 35 so again about a minute and
24 seconds later squad 330
ems code 3. correct so
someone assigned to squad 320 either
officer chauvin or
tao called ems and stepped them up to
code three
squad 330. squad 330 right which was
would be
officer shelvin or officer top correct
all right
and they um code three means
get here as quickly as you possibly can
right correct
um lights and sirens
correct
at now this
particular uh this particular document
exhibit 151 does not have the arrival
times
correct not printed on it no all right
are you familiar with other documents uh
or other printouts that would show
various arrival times
yes and it would show other people who
are
associated with the case
like what time like who is assigned to
which particular squad car
yes okay um if i may have just a minute
if we could take this
down your honor
mr frank i'd be referencing bait stamp
7438
for your information
is uh would it would it
refresh your recollection or would it
help you to identify
arrival times if you were to look at
what's called an incident detail report
yes i'll ask you if
if you can show this screen to the
witness this hasn't been offered your
honor
i'm sorry i can't kill those screens but
not valid
i may have a minute
all right now the incident detail report
has a much more detailed time of
first key stroke of when somebody starts
typing
what time officers arrive every single
time
is documented very closely correct
correct
now would you disagree if i told you
that the phone
was picked up from the 911 caller at 801
and 15 seconds
i can't disagree with that okay and i
know that you don't have this right in
front of you
but because of some redactions i just
have to walk you through this these
times okay
um would you agree or disagree
would you agree that the first unit was
assigned
at 804 and 28 seconds yes
and that that would be squad 330 was
in route at 804 and 28 seconds correct
then 320 took the call at 805
and 11 seconds and indicated that they
were in row so very short time right
very short time
would you agree that if i told you that
squad 320
arrived at cup foods at 808 and 10
seconds
correct
squad 330 being assigned to derek shovin
to
tao squad 830 being assigned to peter
chang of the minneapolis park police
squad 320 being assigned to officers
king and lane
correct
now in terms in terms of
[Music]
here
we're gonna go back to old school
methods and print out some paper
we'll get there
two
to your honor
mr russell
that's fine here right
so for purposes of uh stipulation
ems code two for mouth injury was called
at eight twenty and eleven seconds
squad three thirty was called out at
eight twenty one and thirty five seconds
the arrival time of ems
it's 8 28 and 36 seconds
[Music]
so 8 28 and 36 seconds ems arrives
correct
all right and then ems didn't stay on
scene
right yep they left
and they indicated that they went to
36th and park
right and they didn't go to 36th and
park did they
emits that's that's where i believe they
were
okay um so to your your belief they went
to 36
in part because that's what they called
out correct correct
um do you recall fire having trouble
finding
ems at 36th and park yes
okay because they didn't go to 36th and
park they went to 36 in chicago correct
i don't i don't i actually don't know
that's
after those comments i i did not know
that's where they went
okay so ultimately there was some
confusion between
fire and ems about where ems actually
was
and you heard that radio chatter i
heard the i asked the questions on
matcom which is reflected in there
and then relayed the informations that i
had of 36th and park
which was also added into the call other
than that i didn't know their locations
okay now ultimately um
you said that you were watching this
video
and you were still i mean you were still
watching your rest of your work right
correct i was actively still working
so you're look up for a couple seconds
look down do your work look up
look down from time to time throughout
the course of this incident you're
correct
all right and so it's fair to say that
your attention wasn't necessarily
focused directly on the cameras and what
you were seeing
correct and you but it was concerning
enough to you
what you did see that you called
sergeant pfluger
of the minneapolis police department
third precinct right
i was concerned
yes because of the time of the length of
the incident had not
changed okay so you called and we
listened to your
um video or the audio of your call with
sergeant kluger
and you called sergeant plueger at
8 30 and 44 seconds
is that the time of the call correct
20 30 44. yes and that's the first time
we spoke
so the first time you spoke was at 8 30
and 44 seconds
and in fact during that phone call you
were you must have looked back at the
camera and saw that they were all gone
at that point right
correct because you're like you said
something to the effect of oh wait
they're all gone
right correct and um
your time that you had called into the
the met link
was at
8 31 and 12 seconds
does that sound right to you for the
metcon hill right
correct then ultimately squad 330
indicated that they were going out to
check on the status
and it says ap of the ap that's
something that
squad 330 typed into the system correct
and that was at 855.08
right now again
you were concerned because of the length
of the time
that you saw this incident on unfolding
right
correct and i think you said that at one
point you thought maybe the camera had
even frozen
right because it seemed to be kind of
prolonged right
you can't hear anything on that video
could you
no you had no idea what officers were
talking about
amongst each other or what they were
talking about with others who were
present right you are correct and again
you not being a minneapolis police
officer
are not familiar with the use of force
requirements
correct is that correct all right but
you are aware that when uses of force
are made or used
sometimes you'll hear dispatch the
officer call for a sergeant because they
need someone to review a use of force
right right and you at the time you
called
officer plueger or sergeant plugger you
hadn't received any sort of a dispatch
from squad 320 squad 334 squad 830
hey we need a sergeant to review the use
of force
you are correct now every single time
the minneapolis police department uses
force do they go through the dispatch
process
of over using the radio well to get to
the sergeant to report the use of force
as far as i know okay so you don't know
whether
someone called up sergeant plugger on
the cell phone and said hey we need you
down here
correct and so because at 8 30
when you called sergeant plugger you had
not
yet um heard that dispatch
right correct and sometimes when a use
of force
occur incident occurs that call may be
to the sergeant to review the use of
force
may be fairly quick and sometimes it may
take a few minutes right
sure it just depends on the
circumstances in the situation right
you indicated that um there were these
tvs there are more cameras within the
city of minneapolis
than six or nine tvs worth right
yes are the televisions like are they
split screen
where you can see five or six cameras at
one time
or are they is it one big tv with one
big camera
uh it is split screens and then you can
go into
different camera views okay
just looking back through my notes when
you watched
um the video here in court
you said that it was similar to the
video that you had watched
previously right yes um
would you agree with me that the video
that we just watched in court
seem to be moving very slowly
in terms of kind of choppy pace pace
um yes right um
so an incident that you watched you
watched it in
real time subject to a few seconds of
delay for the signal to get
through right correct so i'm gonna see
if it makes a difference if we look at
it on my computer
so
if we could this is exhibit 11.
yep this should be plugged in
can we put it up
so now when you watch the same video
seems to be moving a little faster time
correct
because these cameras actually transmit
real-time
occurrences correct
and you said that you um
first kind of took notice based on your
estimate
at 8 17. so i'm going to just
skip forward here
this is 8 17 and 38 seconds
so this is 8 17 in about 30 seconds and
this is when you first sort of took
notice of these cameras
on the squawk or at the call center
now in terms of the pacing of this is
this more consistent with real time
yes and one of the things you ultimately
told
agent peterson was how you noticed how
the squad car was
rocking back and forth during the
struggle correct
if you could just watch this and tell me
when you start to see that happen
well it's currently shaking
and now i'm currently shaking
and by rocking back and forth the car is
actually
going forward a little backwards
and it's happening over and over and
over again right
and it's happening happening pretty much
consistently during the course
of the interaction of the officers right
great and that that back door is opening
and closing on the officers
right correct now the other things that
you notice
when you look at this intersection this
is a pretty busy interception right
correct lots of cars coming by lots of
people
wandering about this was may 25th pretty
nice spring day in the middle of
not long after being uh cooped up inside
here
correct
so now ultimately
you observed and and you saw these
officers
using force right or what you believed
to be force
with taking him out of the squad right
or putting them in the squad
yes and there was what you observed
was a struggle between officers and the
person they were arrested right
correct and that the struggle
ultimately resulted in that squad
shaking back and forth correct
and when you ultimately called sergeant
kluger you you said
i don't know if this is a use of force
or not
right correct and sergeant plugger told
you that it could be just a takedown
correct and a takedown wouldn't require
a supervisor
correct ultimately you know that
sergeant plugin responded to the scene
right
and that's is that yes yes sorry and
that's confirmed in the computer
data dispatch or the incident detail
report
correct
i have no further questions at this time
frank can you redirect
let's create just a few follow-up
questions
i'm going to put 151 back up on the
screen for you because i
think in the questioning the council had
asked you about
matt link i think was the term he used i
just want to clarify that two points
and i want to just clarify those times
as well so if we go down to
the time of 2031-12 and if we could just
expand that out so we could all see a
little better please
i think council asked you about this
2031-12
and that being the metcon call
having looked at this you know what time
was your metcom
call so the information i added was at
2033
for the metcomp that is our
resource that we use radio to radio
in the metro so we can be quick
and be able to get information back and
forth
so that 20 302
what is the purpose of that entry right
there what are you reflecting
i'm asking
basically what is the reason why fire
was added
i got on there and asked what it what do
you need fire for
because there were no additional
comments of saying why they were needed
code three
and so what you've typed in there via
metcom
is and you sent out
yes yes is is to tell what
the information that i got uh via matcom
was that ems would like the
fire department for patient condition at
the requested location
of park and 36th so that's the answer
you got is that fire want
um that ems wanted them to go there
correct
so that was information you received
before 20302 but you sent out at that
time
correct there's the time of me typing
and putting it in there
when you have referred to your work
duties that day
you can take it down thank you as
channel one
how does that signify you from other
dispatchers
we have two other channels there's
channel two which is
in charge of the north side and then
there's channel three
who has downtown in the fifth precinct
and then we have a relief dispatcher
who's there to help us
when we take our breaks or when we need
to get up for any given reason
so when you dispatch over channel one
does that go citywide
or just precinct why just on those two
precincts
i have my own dedicated channel
having been questioned by opposing
counsel
um about your call as you sit here today
have you
changed your mind about the reasons why
you called sergeant leaguer when you did
no you were asked about
the number of screens that you have up
looking at all this and still being able
to see what was going on in this call
from the city camera
that's been your work set up for about
seven years correct
okay something you do on a daily basis
just keep track of all these moving
parts yes
and that video that's up there
when it's not sending out work messages
can put up these city cameras correct
correct
but you don't control that correct do
you know who
or what office controls that it can
change if sometimes the supervisors
at our center can pull up cameras um
like i said sometimes we put them on
there just to see what the weather is
especially if we have inclement weather
if there's storms coming through we can
see actually how severe they are when
people are calling in
sometimes they put them up for
incidences if we can see anything
and those cameras can be taken away from
us uh
to the fact that the base which is the
precinct
desk has control over them and can move
them to wherever they need to when they
need to
so what you're saying is that those
cameras where they're appointed
and when they're available to you can be
controlled by
members of the police department correct
and in your six years by this date
and seven years now it's rare
it's a rare incident for somebody to put
that
incident to put an incident up on the
screen like that correct
i have nothing further
all right thank you you may step down
stephen collins next with us
so
thank you your honor your honor the
state calls alicia oiler
um
[Music]
testimonials
and just to make sure that we can hear
you we're gonna have you take your mask
off i'm gonna leave mine on but
before you begin and so we can test out
the microphone
could you give us your full name
spelling each of your names
like my whole name yep alicia murray
euler
a-l-i-s-h
[Music]
thank you very much your honor um and
miss euler
the the key i'm going to give you is
that when you speak you should be able
to hear your own voice over the speakers
all right so just lean close enough to
the microphone to be able to do that
all right uh so first i'm going to ask
you
a few questions so we can get to know
you a little better uh
how old are you 23. 23.
and are you originally from minnesota no
where did you grow up no i'm from
arizona
thank you thank you and you can even
pretend you're yelling at me if
you want to or make your think your
voice hit the back of the room all right
so you said that you grew up in arizona
is that right yeah
what part of arizona um just arizona
the whole state yep okay uh when did you
make your way over
uh to minnesota i don't know
a while ago were you still in high
school
yeah right did you attend
any schools when you moved to minnesota
yeah
where did you go to school in
in red wing minnesota where else did you
go
st uh what's the last grade you
completed through high school
11. okay can you tell the jury
the different cities or towns that
you've lived in since
coming to minnesota
i guess minneapolis minneapolis nice to
redwing for one saint paul and saint
paul
are you currently employed yeah
can you tell the jury a little bit about
the types of jobs that you've
that you've held i
[Music]
used to work at speedway and
which uh speedway do you recall for the
location in
what did you do at speedway at 38th and
chicago
i'm a shift lead chef lead what does
that mean
like uh not like a regular employee but
not a manager like kind of in the middle
okay so um not a lot of us have had the
experience of working as a
as a shift lead at speedway so i'd like
you to
just tell the jury a little bit what
what's your day-to-day job like when you
have a job
i work at a cash register i do paperwork
uh if a customer has an issue i handle
the issues
okay you also work as a cashier
do you have to train other people or
supervisor cashiers
oh sometimes how long did you have that
job
about a year
did you start as a shift lead or did you
have a different position you started as
a shift lead
um can you tell me uh tell the jury a
little bit about the
types of hours you would work there it
was a full-time job
yeah i worked 40 hours a week well i did
you did yeah okay when did you typically
start your shift
um between two or three to closing
10 o'clock was closing was it a pretty
busy store um
it has its moments okay
well i'd like to uh see if you recognize
the area
first i'd like to show just the witness
what's been marked for identification is
exhibit
one
i'm going to show you the first i'm
going to offer exhibit one
and then i'm going to show you exhibit
one if you can take a look at the screen
it's just the one in front of you
all right uh do you recognize what's
shown in exhibit one
yeah do you see the speedway where you
used to work
yeah yeah
all right so um
do you have something that looks like
this in front of you
it's called status all right what i'd
like you to do is just take this
and see if you can draw a circle around
the speedway where you used to work
[Music]
thank you
in the name of the store directly across
the street were you familiar with that
yeah yes what's the name of that store
you ever go in that store or your
customer there
not really not really just a place
across the street where you worked
yeah okay
and then do you see what's uh directly
across the street if you cross 38th
street
uh from cutthroats
yeah do you recognize that building
um yeah i didn't know that's what it was
though
i never really paid attention to it
[Music]
well do you recall whether or not you
were working
on may 25 2020 memorial day
yeah and where were you working at
speedway at speedway all right and do
you recall when you began your shift
and do you recall specifically what you
were doing
at the speedway that day bringing
up customers and uh at the cash register
can you just uh again using your stylus
to
point that he could maybe put a little x
around the area in front of the store
where the cash register would be
right here okay
are you able to see the outside across
the street
from the cash register yeah yes
and you said you began working at three
i'd like to draw your attention to
a little after eight o'clock in the
evening that day
do you recall something that caught your
attention
outside of the speedway um
yeah you tell the jury what
caught your attention um the
police like in that area is always
police
when did you first notice or where did
you first notice the police
um i would say like on the corner
right like diagonal
like across the street
like right here oops okay
and so for the record that's across uh
from cup foods
across 38th street in what is labeled on
exhibit one is dragon walk is that right
yes all right please tell the jury in
your own words
uh what it is you saw that caught your
attention
just the police um try not to cuss
just messing with someone okay and when
you say
messing with someone and thank you for
not cussing but when you see
say messing with someone uh could you
please describe what you mean by that
like um i don't really know how to
explain it just like
disturbing somebody before i found out
who it was
okay now did you eventually find out
who the person the police were uh
disturbing in your life yeah
who was that george bloody had you ever
met this person before
to your knowledge you've never been a
customer in the speedway
[Music]
can you please describe for the jury
what you saw after you first noticed
the police having this interaction with
the person you've
you you now know to be mr floyd
he said it again can you just describe
you know after you first notice the
police having this interaction with mr
flay what
what did you see happen
[Music]
where was mr floyd when you saw him in
handcuffs over here across the street
okay in the area where you first
indicated by the dragon
i believe so yeah and then what did you
see
happen after mr floyd was in handcuffs
i don't remember
what's the next thing you do i remember
this oh god
are you a little nervous today yeah well
that's okay
just take your time and we have plenty
of time to
get through this okay
and so just you know backing up you'd
indicated that mr
floyd was in handcuffs and just think to
yourself
what you next remember seeing after you
noticed using handcuffs
i think they um ended up putting them in
the um
the police car thing and which police
car
would where was the police car saw the
one
right across from craft food okay now
did you see
um the police take mr floyd across the
street
yeah yes all right so after you saw him
in handcuffs you saw him being taken
across the street
and then placed in the car um right
outside of cup foods is that right
yeah yes yes
and uh you own a cell phone correct
yeah you owned a cell phone at the time
uh yes yes and did you do anything
with your cell phone as you began to
notice
this incident involving mr floyd and the
police well as you guys
seen that um on the security thing that
i have my phone
you right you had your phone did you do
anything with your phone
like recording it yes yeah okay
um so
what i'd like you to do first before we
get to the point where you start
recording
just explain to the jury what you saw
after you noticed the police officers
putting mr floyd in the car
um
i don't i don't remember okay i can't
think right now
well um
you indicated that you began recording
with your cell phones yeah right
and uh during the time that you've been
preparing speaking to the police about
this you've
provided your cell phone recordings to
law enforcement is that right
yes yes yes all right and there were a
total of
seven cell phone recordings that you
personally took is that correct
yes you've reviewed each of those uh
cell phone recordings
correct yeah and those cell phone
recordings uh do they fairly and
accurately depict
what you saw on the street that day yeah
and two of those uh cell phone
recordings were actually made from
inside the store correct yes and then
the rest were outside of the store
now those uh cell phone recordings
individual clips
have been marked and disclosed to
counsel
as exhibits two through
eight you wouldn't know that but they
have
and at this time i'm going to offer
exhibits two through eight
yeah yeah
you also had an opportunity to review
a surveillance video is that right yes
and the surveillance video for the
record is exhibit 11.
having reviewed that video but that
video
i'm sorry fairly and accurately capture
things that you observed when you were
working at speedway on the 25th yes
and then you were able to review
that surveillance video in
a format in which all of your cell phone
videos
i guess i should say six of the seven
cell phone videos
had been spliced into or put next to the
surveillance video correct
yes and that kind of gives a perspective
of when those individual videos were
shot
is that correct yes and then the
combination
of the six videos that we've just
received
in exhibit 11 which has been offered and
received
would that composition better help you
and assist you in explaining your
testimony of the jury
yes all right and that for the record is
exhibit nine
i offer exhibit nine any objection
and at this time i'm going to go ahead
and publish exhibit 9
as you take exhibit 1 down
and when i when i say publish i mean i'm
going to play it and at times i'm going
to
stop and pause and have you explain some
things
all right okay okay all right
if we could begin publishing exhibit
nine please
and i believe we're paused at seven
seconds
at this point you can see uh and i'm
going to place a circle
around some the officers you see them
there
and are those the people that you saw
interacting with the person you now know
to be mr floyd
and your first interaction that you
noticed was actually across the street
by the dragon block is that right yes
now
uh as mr floyd's being taken over the
car
i think that we will soon hear
your first recording so if we can resume
play
always
after you made that short recording and
that was you uh
i suppose narrating yes okay
after you were narrating that portion
you continued to watch
yes
you know at this time ms wheeler did you
notice any bystanders anybody
in the street
we're going to be approaching minutes or
8 16 and 30 seconds miss euler were you
continuing to
watch the events as you were working the
cash register at speedway at this time
i believe so yes
all right now we've paused at about 8
17 and at some point did you notice some
other police officers
arrive on the scene
i think so let's resume
play here
okay and let's pause now uh at this time
showing you two other individuals who
are joining the first two officers that
you saw you
notice those yeah and what did you see
those two officers do after they arrive
i don't remember
let's continue
now from your vantage point inside the
speedway were you able to hear
anything outside now
so
all right let's pause here for a moment
and we're at 8 18
and 10 seconds now as best you can
describe for the jury
what you recall seeing the officers do
with mr floyd prior to getting to this
point
before this point before this point for
example
did you see mr floyd get into a vehicle
like off of what we just watched what do
you
what do you recall seeing with mr floyd
and the squad car
before just before we get to this point
when they drag them out all right
let's resume
okay now we're positive about 8
almost 8 19 i asked you previously about
bystanders and noticing bystanders at
some point
as you made these observations did you
see a crowd
of bystanders gather
not to like after after what
like after they did the yeah okay
so at this point you're not seeing a
crowd
either in the immediate area or across
the street at the speedway
i'm trying to remember at all okay
let's resume play
yo you keep going
all right i'm going to pause here
and this is at 8 20 and 20 seconds and i
ask you some questions about some people
again some bystanders
in the area do you know who this person
in the lower
uh left corner wearing sandals and
shorts and a black shirt
yes don't recognize them never seen them
before
do you know the person in the dark shirt
uh hooded sweatshirt and blue pants
no never met her before either no
or how about the child
behind her in the green shirt no not
familiar with her either
if you please resume
i'm gonna pause for a moment here
uh
[Music]
do you recognize that person that
officer
do you recall do you recall seeing an
officer interacting
with a group of bystanders who would
later gather
uh i think so can you physically
describe that person
as best you can remember i don't
really know it's been so long
do you recall previously talking about a
bald police officer
i think in one of my videos i was
talking to a person
bald officer do you recall as you sit
here today what the bald officer did
i think he was like yelling at people
like before or after this
do you also recall of describing a tall
officer
yeah what did the tall officer do
i think he was like i don't remember
there's so much
let's resume play
there's always some [ __ ] going on
pause for a moment now what we heard
there
uh that was imposed at the same time as
the surveillance video was your second
recording is that right
yes yes and again that was your voice
when you said there are always some yeah
right okay uh did you continue to
watch these events uh out the window
that entire time
did i watch it out like outside from
inside
um i think i went outside to smoke a
cigarette
all right i'm going to ask the play to
resume
and ask you to pay particular attention
to your video on the right side
okay
freeze yeah go a little bit further
stop all right now
i'm showing you what appears to be a
reflection
you recognize that yeah who's that
that's
me okay so that's you recording the
events
uh reflected in the window correct yeah
so
based on that would you agree that you
were inside the speedway at the time
this particular recording to me yes
resume please
[Music]
[Laughter]
lots now uh can you please explain to
the jury why did you
continue to record what you were seeing
here
um because i just i always say the
police they're always messing with
people
and it's wrong and it's not right i'm
gonna
then direct your attention to the right
side of the the screen as well
you say that you briefly you see that
you briefly turned your camera away
from the officers in the squad car
towards the area that's right by the
dragon walk is that right
and can you tell the jury what you see
here um i see people standing there
but that's not why i ship the camera can
you explain why you shifted the camera
because that's where it started from
okay so
when you say that's where it started
from i think your description initially
was that there were some officers who
were
to use your words messing with mr floyd
yeah
okay and this is the area in which they
were messing with mr floyd
yeah when it started uh i'd like to
resume play again please
all right let's pause for a moment and
you can see that
your that had been your second recording
has stopped
and at this point we're continuing to
watch the surveillance video please
resume
we get freeze here
let it go just a little further
stop all right so
again asking i've already asked you
about some of the people in the crowd
and you said you didn't know
them i want to add some folks
there's a person in a white t-shirt do
you recognize that person
i don't know that person never seen that
young woman before not
before like this right
and then i think walking by i don't know
if you noticed there was a
couple with a child did you have you
ever seen them before
no
and then there's a gentleman here in a
dark hooded sweatshirt had you ever seen
that person before
please resume
you know at some point you indicated
that you'd uh
gone outside of the store to smoke a
cigarette is that right yeah
you continue to watch these events
unfold as you
uh we're outside of the store yep
as you were watching uh from outside the
store did you see
uh any of the bystanders interact with
the police officers
um i think they were like yelling at
each other i don't really know what they
said i was
kind of too far away couldn't make out
any specific words
no do you recall seeing a woman with a
black shirt and a white headband no
a long time ago
uh go ahead and resume
all right if you could pause
all right i it asked you about seeing a
woman with a black shirt and a white
headband i'm wondering if now looking if
this refreshes your memory
at all about this person
from outside then at your vantage point
outside of the speedway you begin
what is now your fourth recording and i
think for the
record that starts at about uh
was it 8 25 26
please resume
what happened oh
they had him in the other side of the
car and then he pulled him out on the
ground
you could pause for a moment right whose
voice was that
that was mine and were you describing to
uh
someone who is standing next to you what
you just witnessed earlier
yeah okay
if you could resume please
me
you could pause uh it seems that you've
spent a lot of time
watching this encounter yeah and you
were continuing to
occasionally record yeah okay if you
could resume please
2
all right
you can pause did you hear that
ambulance in the background
at some point do you recall an ambulance
actually arriving
i believe so yeah as best you can
remember can you describe what you saw
after the ambulance got there
um i think um the person
uh was going on a stretcher
if we could resume please
stop and uh at this point you can see
that the ambulance has arrived
and there's a ambulance worker coming
out of the passenger side of the vehicle
is that right
yeah in the time
that you've been watching up to this
point did you see
this individual ever get up from his
the first position he was in when he
first uh
went down um i i don't remember
please resume
[Music]
oh
stop all right so
so you see that the street camera has
now changed positions is that right
yeah yes do you recognize that person
that's me that's you okay so that's you
and you're holding your cell phone
yep and that's uh you recording so we
can give the jury a good idea of where
you were
at the time you were taking that footage
okay
and that's when the ambulance arrived
you continued to observe
uh please resume
do you ever see personally observed
officers get up off of george floyd
i think i was more so like i was
recording it but i was also like trying
not to get hit by the cars
coming in the gas station all right
understood
all right if you can resume that please
[Music]
oh all right if you can pause
you can see the stretcher is fully out
here is that right
yeah and then i want to draw your
attention again to the
last officer closest to the to the head
of the individual on the ground
did you see him change position at this
point no
please resume
and then you made your final recording
as mr floyd was
taken from the ground loaded onto the
stretcher
and placed in the back of the ambulance
if you could pause please and then you
see that at approximately 8 29
and 29 seconds p.m mr floyd is fully
placed into the back of the ambulance is
that right yeah
okay please resume
and at that point you would pause please
at 8 29
in about 52 seconds i believe 52 53
seconds
you stopped recording is that right yep
yes
okay um and you can take that down now
but what did you see after the ambulance
pulled away
um there was just a bunch of people
yelling and
fighting and i didn't really understand
why
but now obviously we know why what did
you do
after you stopped um after you stopped
watching outside
i went back to work and that would have
been about right about 8 30
i still i don't remember do you remember
when your shift ended uh
10 o'clock and so you worked up to until
10 o'clock
um do you recall uh what you saw
after you left work that day um there
was much tape everywhere
and they made me like instead of
going down chicago to go home they made
me like go around and like
down the street like all the way down i
think like 30 feet
because the uh the scene had crime scene
tape around it and
you weren't able to access it did you
make another uh recording
of that crime scene tape i think i did
at this time i believe we've already
received exhibit seven
and i'd like to publish exhibit seven
please
um yeah that would be good well you know
what um
i'm almost finished here right yeah if
we could just publish exhibit seven
oh no i'm sorry that's exhibit eight
all right
if you could pause please
and uh ms euler you described the scene
being taped up with crime scene tape and
you weren't able to access it
just show the area where the crime scene
tape was
yes you could resume play please
and stop all right and you can take that
down
what did you do then uh after you made
that recording
i went home and at some point
uh you were contacted by police officers
is that right
yeah they talked to you about what
happened took a statement from you
yeah and you voluntarily provided the
videos to them is that right
yeah okay well uh thank you very much
uh council's gonna have some questions
for you but i think we're to take a
break first
let's take our 20-minute break let's
reconvene at 3 25.
uh
me
[Music]
okay
this is
yes
okay
it
okay
look
[Music]
like this
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's in here
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
right
yes
is
is
good afternoon ma'am
i don't know if that's you or me
so i'd like to ask you a few follow-up
questions if that's okay
okay um if the court would uh
i'm gonna show you exhibit one as we
had before and i think that you
indicated that you
were about right there right when you
first observed
everything yeah all right now can you
just describe for me generally
like the inside of the speedway
like was was you would you have been
facing customers looking out the window
to your right
would you have been standing forward and
looking out the window
um it would be like to my side okay
so if you were in the subway area or
excuse me the speedway area right here
in this area that you talk about like
your
back would have been facing that way
no yes yes yes
yeah and so when you observed what
happened over in this area
you would have been looking back over
your right shoulder
yes okay and that's when you first
observed
oops
that's when you first observed uh the
police interacting with mr floyd
right yes and you observed uh him get
handcuffed or
put in he was in handcuffs at that point
right yes
and you observed them walk him back
across the street towards
the area here where the squad car was
yes correct now again you said that you
were working you were taking care of
customers
things of that nature right yep and
obviously we know that you didn't film
the entirety of the incident from the
beginning to the end
right right and that's because you were
working right
yeah in part at least
and i think as we saw from your video
there were
cars coming in to get gas there were
people coming into the store
that type of thing was happening right
yeah all right
and you ultimately
you remember that you gave a statement
to
an agent with the minnesota bureau of
criminal apprehension
his name was brent peterson would you
disagree if i told you that that was on
may 28 of 2020
okay i i don't remember this sure yeah
we have no reason it was within a couple
of days of this incident right
yeah and do you recall telling uh
agent peterson one of the things that
you didn't understand
was why they took him back out of the
car yeah
because based on what you observed you
observed mr floyd get into the car
both doors were shot correct
and then all of a sudden according to
your video the taller
uh officer just pulled them out of the
back of the squad car
yeah all right now you also um do you
recall testifying or telling agent
peterson
that the people in this area here there
was a female cop
i don't remember
all right yeah sorry um do you remember
a female police officer being there
i don't remember this was so long ago
okay
um would it refresh your recollection to
review
well did you ever have an opportunity to
review a transcript or an
audio recording of your interview with
agent peterson
um
we're prior to coming in and testifying
were you ever given
a copy of your transcript um i've seen
it did you read it um no
okay would it help refresh your
recollection
to look at a copy of your transcript
really
okay so you don't remember ever telling
uh agent peterson that there was a
female officer
on scene it could have been
there's a lot of officers all right
now you testified that you took a first
couple of the first two videos from
inside the speedway yeah and then at
some point you went out into kind of in
the middle of the parking lot
area right yeah or the entrance where
cars would be coming in to get to the
gas pumps
yep you were out there on your break
right yep
and i think we saw based on your video
that what you did is you sort of
zoomed in so you could get a closer
camera view
right and you zoomed it to the maximum
that your camera would allow you to zoom
in
and from where you were standing
ultimately when you were outside
you had the opportunity to make
observations
about what the officers were doing with
mr floyd right
okay would you agree with that yeah
and you had the opportunity to make
observations about
kind of what else was going on right
yeah
in fact i one of the videos you actually
had a conversation with someone else
right
yeah so if you were standing across the
street from where mr floyd and the
police officers were interacting
you would have one view but you would
agree that when we look at a camera
that's just
kind of one perspective right i mean
i guess but there's multiple cameras
though
under i understand i guess what i'm
saying is that when you're recording
your camera is only going to capture
what's out in front
right yeah but when you're recording you
said you were you know looking making
sure you didn't get hit by a car
right so you have the ability to turn
your head from left to right you can
look up you can look down
you can talk to people and you can look
around right okay
but your camera is still in that one
fixed position
yeah all right so you were able to make
observations as this incident progressed
would you agree that more and more
people started stopping and watching
what was going on
yes there were some people standing in
front of you there were some people
standing to your right
recall that yeah and then obviously
there were the people that were closer
over
by where the officers were as well right
yeah and then even on the like
kitty corner from where you were right
there were people standing there
watching
yeah and if you went to your right
on the other side there were people
standing there watching right
i think so right and cars were driving
by and buses were driving by
right and sometimes cars according even
we see in your video they would stop for
quite some period of time and then drive
off right
and would you also agree that as you as
this
incident progressed the crowd of people
started becoming more and more vocal
like what do you mean like well they
started yelling more
i think so right so like that first
video when you step outside and there's
fewer people there's not as many people
yelling right yeah but by the end when
the ambulance takes mr floyd away
there's a fairly large crowd out there
right right
and there's a lot of people yelling okay
i mean would you agree with that yeah
and those people some of those people
you could tell were upset right yeah
i think you you you said that a lot of
people were yelling and fighting
right yeah so you get a sense
you can get a sense that
people were angry
okay would you agree with that yeah
and that feeling
of anger is different when you're there
and watching it than when it is when
you're here talking about it in the
courtroom
i don't think so you don't think i think
if you're still upset about the
situation you're still gonna be upset
about it
i understood but in that moment
you would you would agree when there's
people yelling and there's people
driving by and there's people honking
right that's a different feeling than
you may still be upset here today in
court
it's a much different feeling now than
it is then
okay would you agree with that yeah
all right and ultimately
again you took these various cell phone
videos
um you provided them to uh law
enforcement voluntarily
right yep and then you went back inside
you finished your shift and then when
you left
the scene was taped off because it was a
crime scene right
i have no further questions any redirect
yes
thank you so when you saw the officers
bring mr floyd across the street
did you see mr floyd struggle with or
resist the officers
um no and when
uh the officers first
brought mr floyd to the ground and you
saw the three officers on top of him
there wasn't a large crowd at that time
was there
i don't think so no in fact that didn't
happen until
much later correct yep and you never saw
the officers get up
off of mr floyd until after the
ambulance arrived
after the stretcher was pulled out is
that right uh yeah that's what it said
in the video
we'll show them the video all right
nothing further
all right thank you you may step down
mr frank
yeah the state would call donald
williams to the standard
raise your right hand if you swear or
firm
penalty perjury but the testimony of
your body will be the truth and nothing
but the truth yes i do sir
just to test out the microphone give us
your full name spelling each of your
names
uh full name is donald williams the
second
uh d-o-n-a-l-d
w-y-n-n-i-r-w-y-n-n
last name w-i-l-l-i-a-m-s
the second thank you mr frank
mr williams can you uh tell the jurors
roughly how old are you uh 33 okay
and what do you do for a living i'm an
entrepreneur
um in a professional fight and a father
and a what in a father that takes up
probably as much time as all the others
so you by entrepreneur you have some of
your own companies that you run
that is great various businesses correct
and um tell us the jury if you would
where you live not your address but the
city you're tolerating uh i'm in a
unique situation but uh
i do have a place in roseville in south
minneapolis
and your place in south minneapolis well
are you familiar with
cup foods that is great how far is your
place from cup foods roughly
uh not too far
from cubs so like uh literally
yeah like on the next block too much
not too far down so how long have you
lived in the twin cities area of the
minneapolis area uh minneapolis twin
cities ever
for 33 years pretty much my whole life
i'm a city kid
okay and
mr williams um
well before i forget to ask you you've
done some work in the security field
that is correct uh been working in
security for over 10 years
and what does that mean what do you do
to work in school fire security private
security
uh i worked at the clubs pizza luce um
different clubs downtown minneapolis i
worked at allied security for
a year uh before the situation as well
um and i've done private security for
the mystically kids as well
um so i've been working security for uh
quite a few years and so that means
everything from
i suppose being what we might think of
as a bouncer to
uh just kidding so from being a bouncer
to a private security like i said been a
door guy
uh to like uh escorting someone to
you know uh high-profile athletes as
well too
some of the comedians that he came into
minnesota um
and like i said some of the high-profile
kids uh from mystic lake that
families on mystic lake i have done
multiple private securities for them as
well on different events uh throughout
minnesota
so for for doing that job do you have to
learn some
uh use of force correct uh well my
uniqueness is a
i i'm a wrestler from high school that
developed into a martial artist
so that's what uh helped gave me
more of the opportunity to be able to do
the private security and things like
that
and just heard connections from the
mixed martial arts world from my
previous manager to these different
friends inside of my circle
and when you're doing security do you
sometimes
have the opportunity to work with
minneapolis police officers that is
correct
i have worked side by side with
minneapolis police departments and i
mean after police
since i was 21 21 years old and again
i'm 33 years old right now i work
downtown like
peter luche brought me in a couple of
years ago when one of the top guys
antonio
left to go to vegas and work out in
vegas
he reached out to me and put me at the
door and i was able to control my city
because i have a relationship with
both sides of the city no matter if it's
business streets
uh friends you know different areas my
connection is
pretty broad to the twin cities so i'm
able to
talk certain people out of certain
situations downtown
yeah that's fine okay so um so
working security you sometimes work with
minneapolis police officers
officers who are also working security
that is correct
and sometimes when they're called in as
police officers to an incident
that is correct and
since you mentioned the mixed martial
arts let's talk about that a little bit
um
you mentioned also wrestling and when
did you start
in the sport of wrestling i started in
seventh grade you know or
sir seventh grade yeah i haven't earned
that yet yeah
right hey soon somebody might be upset
if you start calling me
um but uh so you started wrestling
a very young age correct and uh
wrestling is a sport what kind of things
you got to learn
if you want to be a good wrestler that's
correct what kind of things do you need
to learn
uh you need to learn one uh men's the
mentality of being a wrestler
you know it's a it's a hard pace uh
different grind it's not really a sports
lifestyle
um you gotta really learn the technique
of wrestling you know and then it's
different
you got to learn the different
atmospheres of wrestling as well
uh you could be the top guy wrestling in
arena where everyone hates you
and you're just going to get someone
everybody wants you to win so you got to
be able to absorb all that and be able
to move forward and
perform so those things three things you
know and how about the physical aspects
of it what kind of things you need to do
to be a good wrestler physically
to beat your opponent yeah you have to
be able to condition yourself your body
you have to be able to do different
circuits different workouts running
um yeah just conditioning your body to
be able to be a lead wrestler
is there a lot of uh using your weight
uh to control the other person
that is right correct uh you when you
first start wrestling you don't really
understand the weight shifting you're
kind of like falling all over the place
but then eventually you learn how to
control your weight off of someone
else's movement and body movement and
things like that
so you know the different pressures and
you know different
um just movement you know and it's
called flow wrestling you eventually
learn how to flow wrestle
um when it comes to that and it's just
like not being so resistant to
everything you know
so you're saying flow flow w not i could
say light flow
f l o yeah flow w wasn't true because it
float
or flow so o-w so would you tell the
jurors
about your wrestling career uh yeah i
wrestled uh
minneapolis edison uh high school uh
again i started in seventh grade so i
had a fast track and catch up to all the
kids that was already better than me
because most kids wrestled started at
four years old um so
coming into edison i uh they were
really good program at the time probably
the best one since 2006.
i was able to transfer in crack the
lineup at edison and
i was a multiple time state entrance uh
sections champs and i went on and
wrestled
in college as well at uh dctc
i wrestled there for one year and then
went over and wrestled at rctc
which is another junior college so
um and from there i just been growing
into wrestling learning different
wrestling i coach
youth program since i got out of high
school
and i currently coach my kids right now
they're currently wrestling different
friends
uh kids as well and help them develop
their skills
and to do different private lessons and
things like that with them so this all
started from you know me being a seventh
grader
playing in the backyard with some
friends
yes yes thank you so much a little bit
yeah
just to ask you a couple specific
questions you mentioned dctc
correct can you describe for us what
that is what yeah
technical college okay so that's a
junior college presidential college
correct
and the other was rctc rochester
community college
and so you wrestled at the college level
correct
and at some point did you take up mixed
martial arts yes about
sophomore year at rochester um i'm in a
unique situation i have a
kid with me so we kind of uh
shifted towards uh getting our grades
together and
trying to create a plan to finish be
able to wrestle in college
eligibility wise um and
um i end up getting finding martial arts
from different
friends like marcus investors jack
jeusula
jafari veneer and carrie and things like
that they were my coaches at wrestle
and their they wrestled in culture and
they ended up jumping into martial arts
and i came back to visit and kind of
fell into the martial arts world with
him so i mean just
yeah yeah so
you've done a lot of mixed martial arts
so i'm going to try and
you know walk you through it a little
bit but what year was it that you
started
seriously training in mixed martial arts
about uh let's see
22 like 09-ish it's like oh nine
you've been involved in it ever since
i've been involved in ever since career
continue to be involved in it yeah
continue
to be involved in it
as of the last nine months i have not
been training okay
and ever uh ref russell i'm sorry
done the mixed martial arts what we call
it a fight uh professionally
correct amateur i got 10 amateur fights
in about
close to 20 professional fights so
about 2009 you start correct um
through 2020 correct correct how often
during that time period are you in the
gym training
that's uh monday through friday like i
devoted my
my life to uh mitch martial arts and my
kids like to meet smart shirts uh so it
was
a 40 hour or more week job at the
minnesota martial arts academy i was in
there
majority in the morning from 10 a.m to
sometime three
in the afternoon training for uh
hopefully a fight so the mixed martial
arts academy that's the business where
you train
that is the gym i train it correct and
when you were training there did you
ever
have the well did you ever train with
minneapolis police officers who were
there
correct uh describe that for the jury
please um
not everybody uh let every they don't
always let you know that their cop or
cia
agent or fbi agent but we all kind of
link together because they're trying to
learn how to be able to defend
uh different chokes or be able to detain
different people so
um greg nelson which is the head
professor there
he's a unique guy he's been able to work
closely with the military and the army
and the kabata team so
we get a lot of uh army kabata people
coming in
and training with us just so they can
learn how to you know defend yourself
in in war i'm taking it and um yeah so
i've been training the next uh some of
them for
like i said a decade and you know some
of them are minneapolis police officers
training them
yeah that is craig and they're not all
minneapolis police department they're
from all different precincts all
different backgrounds and
law enforcement so when you're training
in mixed martial arts
uh is part of the ultimate goal to
get the other person to submit yeah
that's the goal of it
of it you know everybody gets into
martial arts for different reasons you
know
um as you're rolling and understanding
it yes your whole thing is to be able to
get the person submit
when you do put a choke or a different
submission so let me talk to you about
that
so you're trained on what are called
choke holds correct
and what kind of training do you receive
to do a choke uh where you first you go
into a basic class they teach you the
basic
techniques so jiu-jitsu how to be able
to defend yourself on the back how to be
able
to uh defend off a choke and how to be
able to put someone
in a choke as well and those are some of
the basics
that we learned from them so if we talk
about specifically
chokeholds involving the neck did you
also have to learn about
the structures in the neck that can lead
to a choke correct
there's air chokes and there's blood
jokes and there's limb chokes
so explain the first two uh air choke is
more of um like choking someone they
still have air to breathe
in there you know and they're able to
you know absorb it and feel it you know
and then you also have
a choke where it's a blood choke where
um it specifically
attacks the side of the neck and it
specifically cuts off the circulation of
your arteries and
stops the different beliefs of blood
flowing from body to from top of your
head to the bottom of your head
and sometimes you could get a blood
choke and not know you're in a blood
choke until you
unconscious in your training have there
been times when
you've been rendered unconscious through
a chokehold correct uh i have been
submitted on a professional level in
in live matches uh and i have over 30
probably 30 um jujitsu
submission matches where i have got
caught
in a submission before on a very nice
choke in the front joke
um i only had two been only choked out
twice in the j2 side
but in my martial arts on a fight side
of in a fight
i've been submitting like three times on
a side choke
so in that training do they have to
teach you uh
what that's like so you know to avoid it
yes correct uh so it's a uniqueness you
have to kind of like
be acceptable to being choked you know
you can't just like
be you can uh it's not normal people can
just really get choked you got to relax
you got to be able to breathe
you got to be able to let the choke
happen and you got to be able to know
when to actually tap
tap out on the choke because you're
you're in practice you're not trying to
put this person to sleep
but you're trying to get them to
understand how it feels to be choked so
we do go back and forth
choking each other sometimes you'll see
white stars when you get choked
and it kind of like helps you understand
you know when you went too far you know
and
some people choke tolerances higher than
normal you know some are
really low where when you do put it
choke you're tapping right away and
some people will be able to absorb it
and actually meditate there
because they want to be able to be
comfortable and choke and be able to get
out of the live action
so you use the term tap out and what
does that mean uh so tap out will be
for instance uh so if i have you in a
submission and i feel like it's getting
to a certain point where
it's not comfortable for me i just have
my uh my opponent and my opponent
releases his choke and then we're back
to grappling again
and you know i catch him in a submission
if he's not comfortable
he taps and this goes for the neck limbs
and all that so you don't
harm each other during practice what
what can happen
have you learned through your training
and experience if you don't tap out if a
choke goes too far
if you don't have all you can lose
consciousness and you can
develop different uh i'm not a doctor
but someone needs from your brain to
your body because of lack of oxygen and
things like that
so we
talked about that a lot but i appreciate
you sharing that with us
correct we'll come back to that in a
little bit i want to take your attention
back to may 25th of 2020. you remember
that day
correct and um on that day
at some point did you go to cup foods
correct
and um prior to going to cup foods
that day had you done any activities
with
for instance your son correct yeah so
earlier that day i
just went finished fishing with uh some
wrestling friends for wrestling family
uh me and my son and uh it became
uh caught maybe three bass
throughout that whole day of fishing was
a beautiful day during the day so
everybody was on the lake
so we went fishing and uh caught three
bass uh after
we got done fishing rolled around a
little bit have been fishing a little
bowl
on the side you know the boat swimming
around the water
uncomfortableness um and once we got
done fishing we had to
you know drain the water take our fish
and find some water
to actually transport our fish back home
one you know
safe way i guess to their death um
so we put them uh in a bag and tied them
up and
we pretty much separated them on our way
home
for our ride so that you could enjoy
them later
yeah so we can actually cut them up eat
them and freeze them
which are still in the freezer and
um so at some point then you decided to
go to cup foods why did you decide to go
there that day um
so i went to cup foods because i haven't
cut a fish up in about like
since i was like 23 working at a butcher
i solo grocery store
uh so me and the fish had like we were
like
going through some things and watching
this fish actually die and
watching him lose his ear and watching
his eyes actually roll back from the
back of his head
um so i forgot i'm cutting them up me
and my son was actually watching on a
youtube channel trying to figure out how
to actually cut the fish the proper way
to make sure
that we're doing it right cutting the
fins off chopping the side of the head
off
you know filleting the fish so i thought
i kept doing done doing that
i just needed air for myself so i
went to the store to get something to
drink at the time and i kind of just
snuck out
from the family once i was gonna cut and
fish so did you drive there
that is correct okay i'm gonna show you
something we've already
uh received as exhibit one on the screen
do you recognize what's depicted in that
photograph
uh correct all right and this is the
intersection of
38th in chicago where cup foods is
correct correct
and you will notice on the bench in
front of you
one of these little styluses hopefully
and you can draw on this and i'd ask you
just to show the jurors
where you drove up and where you parked
is it showing up
is it showing up on there no i don't see
it i don't see it either
oh there it goes came from that
ankle so about somewhere right here
all right so for the record you drove
um down 38th street towards cup foods
and parked on 38th mexico foods that is
correct
okay
and i'm going to show you uh
some photographs to sort of help
illustrate what you did that day
all right and i'm going to first
here on our offer exhibit 18.
no objection 18 is received
okay can you put 18 please now
you recognize this photograph correct
this is something we had shown to you
before
it is correct and who is that in the
photograph uh
that is donald williams ii which is me
okay
and is that uh you parked the area where
you parked on 38th
that is correct and that's you walking
up that's great
and uh can you describe for us what
you're wearing the sweatshirt that
you're wearing
uh north side boxing club
so that's not the academy where you're
trained that's just another club no
there's not as a youth
gym and so when you decide to go to cup
foods did you
you know get all dressed up and get
ready for
going out no not at all okay
uh this is just an outfit you threw on
that is great
when you were um on your way to cup
foods did you grab your cell phone and
take it with you
that is great you got it with you yeah
that is great all right
and um so after you got out of your car
as you walked up towards cup foods
um did you notice any police cars in the
area that is incredible
okay describe for the jurors and kind of
what you saw as you're walking up
as you can tell my face expression um i
was kind of like oh police is here and i
know he said there was uh
two public squad cars out there and i
just had to look on my face like oh
we're in the city something else is
going on
uh should i get back to my car or not
okay and what did you decide to do
uh my energy just kept
pushing me forward and i kept walking
okay
and so you kept walking towards the
store that is correct i
started working towards club foods
insurance and did you end up going into
cub foods
uh no i did not make it into cup foods
why not what stopped you
my energy stopped me uh the surroundings
stopped me
the energy of the air just me as a
person people know me personally
it's just the energy was off i couldn't
like get in the door for some reason and
then once i
realized wow so when you came around so
cup food sits on the corner correct
that's correct so 18 shows you're
walking up on the 38th street
side correct when you get around the
corner
what is it that starts you know affect
your energy and
your decision to go in the store or not
yeah so
i'm just sitting at the door just like
man is so much going over here
do i involve myself because i'm used to
that usually you know
a patient's in my city so i was
contemplating with myself do i involve
myself or do i go inside the store
um i started hearing different um voices
from people that they know you know
telling someone that they
just calm down everything's gonna be
okay and then
uh i heard you know some people said
that you know i'm looking for
some point for their mother and i heard
another voice
just saying that you know you should let
them up and they're not resisting the
rest
there's just certain things that just
kept hitting me while i was standing
there like
should i go in the door or not and did
you go into the store then
i did not go to the all right so now i'm
going to show you
uh well first i will offer exhibit 19.
any objection no usage
please and do you recognize what's
depicted in this photograph
that is correct and is that you then
walking um
along chicago that is great welcome
chicago
all right so when you get into this area
is this
well what are you experiencing right
here where you're walking along
well again like i said i was just
hearing different motions different
comments
and at this point i just was kind of
like
deserving so i kind of like slowly tried
it over there
and we can see in exhibit 19 there's a
couple other people on the sidewalk here
did you know any of those people as you
walked up
no i did not know no one out there
at all the first people that you see
while you're there
um well you stayed at that area for
quite a while correct
that's great so the people that you
first see as you're walking up
uh can you kind of describe how they
looked or how they appeared to you what
who they were correct uh again um i
didn't uh
i don't know none of them um i just
remember off of certain visualization
that it was
three people uh outside it was an older
guy a younger lady
and uh maybe one more other gentleman
out there and
yeah and then uh this photograph also
shows uh in front of you a person with a
green shirt do you remember seeing that
person no no
okay like she wasn't like and you know
she was there but i didn't see her
okay and so you um
well from where you are in this
photograph where did you go what did you
end up doing
mom i believe i ended up probably
standing next to this little spot right
here
where she's standing at point i probably
was
standing somewhere here after i came
from this way
and i just sat there and chilled right
in this area
for a second observing like security
officers do uh deserve the scene first
before i spoke
and as you observed it um
what are you seeing and hearing uh
well once i get there i hear an older
guy saying it's gonna be okay
quizzes and the rest uh they're gonna
get you up and put you in the car
and just hearing people different people
actually vocalizing
their concerns to the officer and
hearing george on the ground
pretty much pleading for his life saying
he's sorry i can't breathe
with my mom just please let me up and
things like that
so you know while we still have um
exhibit 19 up can you show the jury
after you
got done observing where did you go from
there uh
my prayer me up so ended up somewhere
in this vicinity throughout the whole
time
okay and so when you went over
uh by the curb area there um what did
you see happening on the ground behind
the squad car
well before i walked up i i noticed that
it was the officer
standing right here kind of um pretty
much
dictating the crowd from only standing
on this curve right here where they're
at
you know that part right away and then i
finally noticed
uh it's going to be an opposite side but
i noticed uh
george's head was kind of sticking out
from the side of the car
and then i noticed uh officer chavez
right here with his
knee circulated on george's neck but
this is all
happening on this side of the car all
right we'll get to that in just a second
while we're still on this photograph
um when you went over there uh initially
did you leave the curb and go onto the
street
there is a possibility that i was
battling with myself to stay
on the curve and throughout the time
correct we know later you
went under the street area but when you
first got there did you stay on the curb
yeah when i first got there i stayed
right here i didn't move too much right
there i'll stay here and
i might have stepped down once or twice
back and forth but
i can 100 remember and you saw an
officer standing in that area
you showed us before do you did you
learn later that officer's name uh yeah
right badge his uh
um
can i say his name right now no but at
the time i think
i caught him by his name from his badge
he's from visualization
reaching his badge was it officer tao
correct
all right and you were able to read that
from his badge on his uniform that's how
much respect i tried to give him
and so you saw him there correct
and what did you understand his role to
be when you were
observing he was a dictator you know he
dictated what went on on the curb
he controlled the people he controlled
me
and he uh he was the guy that
lay go on why went on
now um you mentioned mr floyd
where was this individual you referred
to as mr floyd can you please repeat
that
sure where was this individual that you
you have referred to as mr floyd
mr floyd again was on this side of the
car
angled down by the tire area in this
area
but on this side of the car
and at this time
[Music]
well prior to coming into court did we
show you a photograph
of the officer with mr floyd on the
ground can you please
be there yeah prior to court today did
we show you a photograph of that officer
with mr floyd on the ground
that is correct that photograph did it
fairly depict what you saw
when you got there first that is great
your honor tonights and i would offer
exhibit 17
any objection
now i'm going to show exhibit 17 on the
screen and
um so this is what you saw when you
uh came to that area on the curb there
yeah this is what i saw and the only
reason why he's looking at me right now
is because i told him it was a blood
joke okay
we will come back to that in a in a
little bit um
when you
were there was mr floyd
able to speak that is correctly
um he was speaking
in a distressed way
and uh what kinds of things led you to
believe you was distressed
uh he was vocalizing it to the officer
he said my stomach hurt i can't breathe
my head hurts i want my mom and
um yeah those are the things that he
repeatedly said he wanted to get out of
the car he said he's sorry for what he
did
he pleaded with my mans and told him i'm
sorry
i shouldn't pretty much
and so did you feel like you could have
walked closer from this vantage point on
the curb
i could have i felt that way in in a way
but it's a
fear factor as well
and at this time so you had seen officer
tao
and you had seen this officer in exhibit
17
correct on mr floyd did you see any any
other officers at the scene at that time
no i did not and so
this in exhibit 17 shows the vantage
point you had the view you had from
where you were standing correct i only
had
that side view of the two officers in
the shoulder length of george floyd's
head
nothing else and
um when you were in this location
can you describe uh for the jurors
what you saw about mr floyd how he
appeared
well let me back up just for a second
because you've used mr floyd's name you
did you know him at the time
i did not know mr cloy at all no really
okay
so you're using his name because you've
learned since then
who he is correct uh can't go
too many places without not knowing his
names in his face
so when you're in this location you
first come up and you're seeing him
he's able to speak correct can you
describe what you saw of mr floyd's
condition as time progressed here
as time progressed so when i first like
i said when i first arrived in the scene
mr floyd was
vocalizing his uh his sorryness and his
pain
and his uh distress that he was going
through
um the more that his the knee was
broccoli
on his neck uh and shimmy as we're going
on
the more you see floyd fade away
and slowly fade away and like the fish
in the bag
you've seen his eyes slowly you know
pale out and again slowly roll to the
back of his eyes
and then um so this is what i seen this
so i heard and that's
you know what it was like he was going
to distress because
of me and he vocalized it that i can't
breathe i need to get up and i'm sorry
and his eyes slowly roll to the back of
his head he's seen the blood coming out
of his nose
you heard him telling me tell him before
he stops speaking
that my stomach hurts and those most of
times is the last bowel movement
of your life so from there on
he was lifeless he didn't move he didn't
speak he didn't have
no life in him no more on his body
movements
during that time period did you notice
anything about his
breathing that was significant to you
yes
just like in mma you could tell when
someone gets tired you can tell when
someone's
getting choked out or things like that
his breathing was
getting tremendously heavy and
tremendously harder for him to breathe
and you actually could hear him
you could see him struggling to actually
gasp for air while he was trying to
breathe
and he barely could move while he was
trying to get here
you were standing there
uh did others gather around
correct at the moment i was the most
vocalist person out there pleading for
floyd's life because i
felt like it was definitely in a room
and um
there was at one point in time a medic
came on scene
and she spoke on checking pulse what
made me even go even more
harder because i heard it and then i
registered it like oh
you do need to check his pulse oh he is
not moving like oh you just killed this
man
you know and so her expertise
was like look he's fading away you need
to check his pulse she's asking him
multiple times
i'm asking him multiple times no one
checked his class
do you remember officer tao saying
anything um
during this time period yeah he uh he
did what
american does and he blamed it on drugs
for being a black man on the ground
let me just tell you what what did he
say about drugs
he said this is what drugs do to you
i reply this is not what drugs do to you
so
did that officer tao saying that
help the situation no it didn't i i if
i'll be honest with you
pissed me off more because that wasn't
the case
so um when you were
um there
um seeing this
did you draw on your training and
experience
in wrestling and mixed martial arts to
draw some conclusion about what this
officer in exhibit 17 was doing
can you go ahead and repeat that yep
it's kind of a long question yes it was
as you're standing there seeing what
you've described to the jury
did you draw on your training and
experience in wrestling and mixed
martial arts
to get an idea of what this officer was
doing physically there great yes so like
as i'm standing there and observing
everything
um before i even spoke if you've seen
the video
um i watched what was going on and as
his position here before i even spoke to
the officer i watched at the position
one of where the position of the net or
the knee was on the neck
you know two what body movements was
going on while
he why the knee was on the neck and then
three what was the condition
of george floyd why he was going through
the
to pursue this uh torture one was that
the neck was
diagonal across the throat which on a
blood choke you attack the side of the
neck you know
in which you're in a kimora or um
or side chokes or things like that you
want to attack the side of the neck
to cut the circulation of the breathing
from your person
and then get the choke tighter you hit
different shimmies
which i felt the officer on top was
shimmying
to actually get the final choke in while
he was on top to get the kill choke
because a side choke or blood choke
can ultimately turn into death and
that's what we see here
and so
to disregard the last uh statement by
the witness
just for the record in the last
statement about
it last statement
and so did you think you know based on
your training experience if this looked
like
a blood choke that is correct and did
you
say that to the officer that's correct
and
how did he respond when you said that to
him uh he looked at me right here it's
the only time he looked at me when i
said it was a blood joke it's the only
time he looked up
we looked at each other dead in our eyes
yeah and when i said it he acknowledged
it
and um like we're looking at each other
right here last statement is
sustain is non-responsive and so when
i'm sorry and
uh
mr williams from that vantage point
depicted in
exhibit 17 that officer do you see that
person present in the courtroom today
that's correct he's standing right there
the aaron has the record to reflect he's
identified the defendant
and hearing it
when you were there at the scene
did you at one point tell the officers
that you were trained at the academy
that's correct and what did you mean by
academy uh
a shortening for the meech martial arts
[Music]
academy
now as this was happening did you
or i'm sorry did other people eventually
come to the scene that's great
and i'm going to show you
what's been marked as exhibit 184
before we put that up uh your and i
would offer exhibit 184.
all right we'll come back to that later
um
when this crowd was uh there do you
recall roughly how many people were
there
no i don't know um
at uh any time did you hear anybody
threaten to harm the officers no
um well i would say arm
i mean some kid came the kid that might
have called the police
i'm not sure exactly from when i talked
to him after the situation but
he did come out once he realized what's
going on and he tried he almost
like tried to rile the crowd back up and
i just kind of like
not just chill out it's too late you
can't do that just go back inside inside
so that was the only incident and when
you did that to him
did he go back inside yeah he went back
and started crying he was a younger kid
now earlier you mentioned the term
shimmy
i'm just been spelling s-h-i-m-m-y good
enough
yeah i never never gave a
spelling everybody and so
that's a move that you learn in your uh
training for
mixed martial arts holds yes and what's
the purpose of doing a shimmy
pick at the the choke tighter to close
the gap of the air
between your arm and the neck and
were there times that you saw things
that you thought you recognized as a
shimmy
by this officer i'm mr floyd that is
definitely correct
your honor just for the record we are
going to show a portion of a video
that i think council will stipulate to
its admissibility
we'll lay full foundation for it
tomorrow and i'm only going to show a
portion of it for this witness today
that's exhibit 15. any objection to the
partial
exhibit 15 and will be received subject
to later foundations
now mr williams you did not take any
video at the scene yourself
that is correct no video um
we had an opportunity to show you a
video earlier
and did that video fairly and accurately
depict what you were seeing there
from a live angle yes from myself
what i'm going to do is play a portion
of exhibit
15 and it's the time period roughly when
you are there
and while we play it i would just ask
that you
explain to the jury the things that you
saw
um you would consider a shimmy to sort
of explain how
uh what it is that you're seeing to make
you think that correct all right
yes all right so we'll do exhibit 15
starting at 44
[Music]
he just did it right seconds you see his
foot
is under his toe is pointing down and
you will see
a small adjuster in his back foot like
this
and that's just the pressure you push
more down between
his knee george's head and the concrete
and cut
off circulation all right and we'll
continue on then please
please do it again
we saw that movement there that reversed
the nail in his foot this time his foot
came up off the ground so no putting him
on the underground
so all the pressure is on his neck and
you're talking about the same
the foot on the same leg as the knee yep
so
correct so the same foot underneath so
it's like this is a choke here so
this is for instance my neck here and
then for me to close this
chimney
and now i close
for instance my neck would be here so i
would have this across
here and i'm closing it off here pretty
much the angle of his
knee and then every time i'm [ __ ]
i'm getting this right here
to close the cap closer within my neck
and it's the same way that you
can do without having the neck across
here so we'll continue on with the video
then
yeah come on what do you want
i can breathe
so what we'll do is we'll wait now we've
uh stopped the video at this portion and
if you could just explain what you're
seeing here
that uh leads you to believe this is a
shimmy type move
so explain that correct okay cool so um
the gestures and the movements is from
his shoulders to the top
and this is he's just doing it with his
knees not you know it's not an actual
choke on
with the hand so he's actually pushed
putting the same pressure
as you would with your neck and like you
said every time the shoulder is moving
pushing that pressure down on his neck
from the shoulders to the knees all the
way from his ankle
and you will see his shoulder shift and
you'll see the bottom of his knees shift
and his foot come off some the one time
he took his foot off
the ground and put multiple pressure now
he's not
on the ground he's driving off his far
foot
and you know as you're seeing this are
you also
seeing things on mr floyd's face that
you testified to earlier
correct so let's continue with the video
get up
[Music]
uh
you